au lac est un jour donné sur it's always
monde et c'est un petit jeu indé gratuit
keller pepsico logique aussi c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui au travail qui
s'appelle bob et il travaille dans un
bureau comme ça et j'ai aucune info de
plus donc on va découvrir ensemble je
crois je lance des explications que j'ai
pas d'infos ça des fois j'ai un saut que
toute ma vie je dormais avec les yeux à
moitié ouvert un gros coup de vent me
donne l'impression que quelque chose n'a
changé donc je crois que s'arrêtera dans
un bureau tout en tous les jours et il a
la même routine et ses cinq étapes de
plus si tu seras libre
oui oui camille sée qui le psychopathe
qui aimait ça j'ai mon pc je peux
travailler ou aller sur chatroulette et
bob comment ça va tu es toujours coincés
dans cet endroit
de quoi tu parles je suis en chaleur tu
as toujours un copain ouais il a marqué
autre chose il a commencé à écrire tu as
toujours un copain puis il a arrêté il a
marqué oublie ça et là personne ne
répond bob je peux te voir agoniser
je t'envoie un fichier ouvre le si tu
veux sortir de ces endroits qu'est ce
que c'est ou attends attends attends ça
va trop vite entre nous au presse
achetée au hyde c'est ce que je fais non
non mais j'appuie sur h
il va me virer mais va mesurer le con ça
marche pas ben je suis viré mais bien
sûr j'ai appuyé sur hltv rebonds et
croyais à 9km usa il travaille monsieur
quatre étapes et tu seras libre
on a fait une offre une se fait
reprendre par son bon centre de mater
des photos de filles sur kindle ne fait
pas ça je vous jure que ça pas du tout
vous amener la liberté ça vous amené que
des emmerdes
ok allez on va travailler au il
fait du excel or c'est horrible je peux
être le pc et wii alors qu'est ce qu'est
ce que j'ai à faire
est-ce que j'ai des poteaux et si j'ai
un collègue mais j'ai un collègue qui
s'appelle baume aussi on est tous bob
c'est ça la blague en mode tous les
mêmes
voilà c'est ça s'appelle tous bob tous
les mêmes j'ai compris la métaphore par
la bob 2 il a toujours des bonnes idées
bob de kebab de kebab de ici bob bob bob
bob bob de il aida il s'amuse à lancer
des boules et de papier dans la
corbeille et ils y arrivent très très
bien beaucoup de talent inné pour moi un
mois les bureaux et kas qui sont en
cuisine et je t'aiderai à s'échapper et
bien sûr bordeaux lui barrant le bois
sidi rien comme au lycée qui c'est qui
prend ses board s'est jamais bob dewar
risque est chaud c'est très glauque
cette boîte très épuré
mais très glauque en moi de les gens
sont tous les mêmes quoi faut tout la
même chose on tue le même pc le même
bureau la même gueule
alors c'est quoi les bureaux car c'est
ça oui alors j'étais burqa se moque
d'eux tu va m'aider à m'enflammer je
tiens mon gars les briques as hatten
classe pour moi comment un texte qui ok
ça ouvre quoi et ouvre un bureau secret
assez sarsgaard et excite je peux ouvrir
leur chair ou pas tant parce qu'on peut
explorer on n'a pas exploré un autre
bureau
mais bob est absent bob est absent le
patron est dit rien les mecs faucon faut
qu'on défonce le patron venait le voir
un mec
bob est absent tu dis rien n'entre pas
dans mon bureau retour travail esclave
il sait pas qui en paie du mois bob
hayes alors où nous mène donc cette
porte de sortie ça la question dans un
dans l'espace fumeur ça avec d'autres
bob open door temps c'est agréable de
travailler dans cet endroit quand même à
temps va on va s'isoler sur le petit
îlot attention j'adore ce travail on va
s'asseoir je suppose ouais on s'assoit
on va contempler ces marais arbre très
très beau avec cette petite fleur qui
tombera transition trois trucs de plus à
faire et on sera libre je pense qu'il
faut casser les couilles au patron à mon
avis il faut forcer auprès du patron et
je me rends ce qui veut dire quand ils
disent qu'on sera libre qui s'ils
veulent dire mon gars c'est ça la
question je peux pas le défoncer et pas
moi je défends ce jeu tu pètes se livre
sur son crâne chauve là à paix s'ils
voient là à je peux pas lutter à la
chaise c'est la meilleure blague du
monde en fait j'aurais pas dû jouer à ce
jeu aujourd'hui je suis d'humeur à faire
n'importe quoi et je joue un jeu très
poétique en plus de celle du politique
avec the last guardian a on peut
s'asseoir et écrire c'est ça on va faire
un origami sa part sur un avion ça alors
su me permets de l'afev et passants il a
fait quoi il a fait un poisson peut-être
que ça pourra rendre quelqu'un heureux
il est mignon il est mignon bob cadets
ya peut-être mais qui a regagné son
bureau et je vais devoir deviner qui
sait pour lui offrir ce merveilleux
poisson en feuilles amel à regarder yaye
une pièce je n'avais pas eu bat ccl
annonçons poisson est mort au nom ma
pauvre est ce que tu peux trouver un
poisson différents ben j'ai exactement
ce qu'il faut il a des petits poumons en
papier en feuilles à petits carreaux
tiens je te le mellah ouais ça a marché
2 2 trucs à faire ce jeu passionnant mon
gars que je comprends toujours pas
pourquoi il a par jour la fille du début
mais bon c'est bob c'est bob il est
touchant c'est un homme tout chaud ça
nous sommes ravis qu'un jour ça je me
dis que j'ai vraiment de la chance des
tubes eur puis à qui ce que j'aimerais
pas vos cd dans un bureau comme il ya
plein de gens qui le font ils sont très
courageux bien plus courageux que moi
avec mes vidéos a ici à des casiers sol
ya un an et trois non mais ça fait de la
musique donc je pense qu'on va retrouver
une partition quelque part et faire de
l'asie car peut-être dans ce bureau là à
regarder ya un casier c'est fermé merde
pour trouver une clé d'une note open
book avec la clé parfait on ouvre fuck
c'est glauque on est surveillé de ouf en
fait
ah merde
what the fuck oh tiens j'ai giflé
c'est un réflexe naturel attend le mec
il a allumé gilad sixième sens de f2p il
sent quand quelqu'un touche aux caméras
qui espionnent les gens d'accord une
étape de plus et tu seras libre à
j'entends du vent y'a plus il ya plus
aucun bob coke un bob hope de fuck
mais non il va se suicider comme si la
liberté finalement c'était de mettre fin
à sa vie maintenant
simek je crois que si ça freedom
[Musique]
et bé un jeu très qui fait réfléchir qui
fait bien réfléchir moi j'avoue dès que
j'ai eu mon bac je me suis consacré à
youtube à plein temps dont je n'ai pas
connu un métier plus traditionnels c'est
pas moi caissier travailler dans un fast
food de traders un bureau est jean
sérien peu importe ton betty plan porte
à vittel routine qui s'installe il faut
juste savoir la mouvementée un petit peu
savoir trouver quoi faire j'ai pas avoir
une passion pas recommencer les jeux
vidéo il en est peut être la flûte
j'en sais rien c'est ce qui me fait
kiffer c'est ce à quoi tu penses quand
tu fais ta petite routine qui t'emmerde
un peu tu penses aux trucs cool que tu
vas faire derrière et arriva à passer au
delà et balla non le gars pour lui la
liberté c'est se suicider voilà c'est
non ça c'est non ça je dis non bref
c'est encore un jeu qui me fait me
rendre compte à quel point j'ai de la
chance mais qu'il veut c'est marrant
quand il ya des gens qui vivent ce
qu'ils vivent ça qu'ils sont très très
mal parce qu'ils ont une vitrine qui se
répètent une salle routine qui les fait
chier n'arrive pas en sortir il ya rien
de nouveau rien n'est fait kiffer
faites-vous qui fait j'en passe et rien
aujourd'hui à 10000 moyen de qui fait de
se divertir d'apprendre des choses
surtout avec internet
alors foncez dommage que l'un de vous ça
jouer de la flûte de ouf et kinshasa
morceaux bon à savoir garder n'hésitez
pas à mettre 1 pouces bleus j'aime bien
j'aime bien j'aime bien les petits jeux
comme ça qui font réfléchir action assez
psychologique et vous avez l'air d'aimer
ça aussi donc ça fait très plaisir ça
prouve finalement qu'on a grandi tous
ensemble qu'on mûrit c'est beau c'est
vrai je suis sûr qu'ils avaient fait jeu
il ya quatre ans les gens mouraient
aurait pas qui fait quoi et même moi
j'aurais pas kiffer à la semaine
prochaine doit savoir garder portez vous
bien il m'a flingué j'avais de l'énergie
sur téléphone et l'aiba il me fait
réfléchir de ouf le jeu allez on finit
toute la journée comme ça sur son siège
à très vite c'est long
[Musique]